- On this episode we try
to keep old minds happy,
we talk about selfies,
and I don't remember.
Enjoy the show.
(bouncy music)
You ask questions, and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, it's Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 53
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
Before I get into this episode,
as you can tell, the setting
has changed a little bit.
Episode 38 we told you we would
get to floor 15, and we have,
and before I get into the questions,
I have one other thing to say.
Just a couple episodes ago, I talked about
how DRock was one of the
worst basketball players
I had ever seen with my own two eyes.
However, last night at the
VaynerMedia holiday party
we teamed up in Cornhole
and completely dominated.
Is Andy K around anywhere?
Cause he's devastated of
what happened last night.
DRock, when I teamed up with him,
because of the lack of
hand eye coordination
I saw in the basketball court,
I expected me to completely have to
put his body on my back
and carry us to victory.
However, the man absolutely dominated
alongside with me, did we go four and O?
Four and O, let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Eddie
asks, "What three values
"do you hold highest in life?"
- Eddie this is a great question.
You know, I don't know
if I have three values
that I hold, I'll just
start rattling off things
that I really appreciate.
You know, I think the
first, you know, thing,
and I don't know if this is in any order,
but I'm a humongous fan of patience.
Lack of patience has caused so many people
from not achieving the
upside that they deserve,
and that kills me.
You know, the value of (spits) this.
Word is bond, I think really matters.
I think, you know, having
somebody in your life
that you just know that you can trust
because when they say
they're gonna do something,
they do it, and then in a weird way,
contradicting that, but not really,
I'm a huge fan of somebody who's nimble
and empathetic, because when
you really think about it,
I, for example, am telling
you that I love (spits)
word is bond, but then when somebody
actually (spits) does that,
and doesn't deliver on it,
in a weird way, I'm okay with it.
And I'm very attracted to
that own characteristic
within myself, because
I think I understand
that even though you really wanted to,
you know, something
happened that made you not,
and I want to dig into why, and so I think
nimbleness, or empathy is
very, very, very important.
I think people that are grateful
are extremely attractive,
you know, nothing's more ugly to me
than somebody who's spoiled, and I think,
you know, at some level,
hypocrisy is the thing
I hate the most in the world.
So, the opposite of that,
which is maybe (spits) that,
or I don't know, but those
are things that come to mind.
- [Voiceover] Chris asks,
"Has the selfie replaced
"the autograph?"
And, "How will it go down at
Wine Library on Saturday?"
- Chris, the selfie has
replaced the autograph.
Straight up, how will it go on Saturday?
And you're referencing the Wine Library
from 11 AM to six PM appearance,
that so many of you in the VaynerNation
are not coming to.
I read the comments yesterday,
you know, I don't understand how a man
can't convince his girlfriend to take
a drive from West Virginia.
You know, if you need to make me call her,
I will, email me her phone number,
I'll convince her on the
phone in two minutes,
and I'm not even her boyfriend.
So, anyway, what's gonna go down
is this, I think a lot of people
are gonna come, both in the business
and the wine world, a lot of them
are you old time friends
that grew up watching
WineLibraryTV, maybe even people
I knew when I was a kid,
growing up in the store.
So, that will be fun, but I expect to take
a whole lot of these, absolutely.
And more interestingly, one of the really
interesting phenomenons
that I'm seeing in trends
is how many kids are actually printing out
selfies with famous
people and then posting
them in their lockers.
I think it's really interesting, and so,
for sure that is now the social.
You know, autographs are social currency,
they represent, you can go in your seat.
- Oh okay.
- Go ahead, you can go in your seat.
It's your seat.
The autograph showed, the autograph showed
kind of like that social, you know,
equity that like, "Hey,
I met India, right."
And so now the selfie's
even more powerful,
more scalable, it has 100%
replaced the autograph.
- [Voiceover] Jimmy asks,
"What's your favorite
"city in the world to drink wine in?"
- Jimmy, my favorite city in the world
to drink wine in is the city
that has my friends and
family in it at that moment
that I'm sharing that wine with.
There is no, like you know, atmosphere
that dictates my happiness
of drinking wine, there's
no pretty french riviera,
or the gorgeous mountains,
I don't give a crap
about that stuff, what I care is
who am I drinking it with?
So, I could be in Newark,
big ups to Newark,
not dissing, if it's with somebody I love,
and we're enjoying wine, then that's what
is the driving force,
and so then it would be
Newark, the hotel lobby in Austin,
in south by 2007 is one
of my favorite times
of all time of having wine.
The parking lot of a Jets game,
you know, inside the caves
of wineries in Tuscany, like it's happened
in a lot of places, but
it's never been the setting.
I don't care about that stuff.
It's been the people I'm sharing it with.
- [Voiceover] Bill asks, "I'm
in sales for third generation
"residential construction,
getting my at bat.
"How do I increase business,
but keep old minds happy?"
- Bill, that's a great question,
and I've got to set this up.
I may not be the right
person to answer this
because my answer comes
with straight venom.
So get ready.
I truly believe the way
that you get old minds
to accept, consume your new ways
is to be extremely rogue and aggressive,
and massively disrespectful to them.
I get it, but old minds are tough to move
if you're gonna play within the lines
that they draw you're not gonna be able
to do what you want.
At some level, I had empathy
and respect for my dad,
and the truth is he
gave me plenty of room,
so I didn't even really live this,
but I live it now with VaynerMedia
where I'm trying to move old minds
where they're B to B,
and they're not my dad,
and they don't know my
brilliance sometimes upfront,
and they're not quite sure, and
it's hard for me to move it,
and one of the ways to move it
is to be out and out disrespectful.
I'm telling you right now, I get it,
and you don't want your
grandpappy firing you,
and I understand all those dynamics,
but the truth is if you
want to move mountains,
it's not gonna be by like (blows),
you can't get it done like that my man,
and so to make change, to move things
in the right direction, you've
got to come with thunder.
It's just the way it is,
and so you've got to be
a little disrespectful, you've
got to tell them they're old,
and, and this is the big
one, if you God forbid
get your chance to do
it, you better execute,
because if you don't,
then you're just a kid.
Then you're just naive,
then you're just young.
And it's international mountain, show
he deserves it, show it,
he was paying attention
to the show, he was paying
attention to the show,
that's unbelievable.
- [Steve] You could just crowd
source stuff by saying it.
- Yeah, you know what, these guys
are a hell of a lot more fruitful
than that closed off, I like these guys
more than I like you guys I think now.
Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Michael asks, "Hope you had
"a great time at last
night's holiday bash.
"What's your favorite holiday tradition?"
- Michael, hands down, my
favorite holiday tradition
is Thanksgiving, just
goin' to my parents' house
in Hunterdon County.
It's just somethin', I
don't know, I just love it.
Obviously, we talked about
it a couple episodes ago,
but it's really just you know,
I think you get the theme,
it's happened twice here,
I'm a people person,
I'm a family guy, that's the one
that's almost like the non-debatable.
My dad screwed up birthdays
a couple years ago
by taking my mom to Italy on the birthday
and breaking up the family dynamics,
and now I always razz him for that,
because then I had a really
dear friend get married
during my mom's birthday,
and we went away,
and so now it's broken up a little bit.
Birthdays used to be pretty sacred.
The family shifted a
little bit on that one,
but Thanksgiving is like,
"We've got to be together,
"we've got to be at mom's."
And it means a lot to me, I get to see
everybody I love so much,
and there's so, you know.
The football games, and the me and AJ
doing something crazy like we bought
expensive basketball cards this year.
You know, just, it's always a lot of fun,
my sister's kids, blah
blah blah blah blah.
So, Thanksgiving, getting together,
nothing too crazy, nothing
too, you know, wild,
but that's the scoop.
Is that it, India?
- [India] Yeah.
- Alright, question of the day.
Give me a little feedback
on your new settings,
VaynerNation, what do
you think about this,
how do you like it, do you enjoy it?
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
VaynerNation, I need you
to start tweeting questions.
I think we've done a
bad job by reminding you
how this show works, which is you've got
to ask me a question, use the hashtag
#AskGaryVee, and then you get on the show.
Dig deep VaynerNation, dig deep.
- Gary, I have a question for you,
do you think the reason the
Jets are so bad this year
is cause you made a deal with the Devil?
(bouncy music)
- Don't forget to subscribe
to my YouTube channel.